you know I love this idea of radical
openness free exchange of information
the free flow of ideas creating spaces
in which ideas can have sex as Matt
Ridley talks about and this is huge
because turns out that ideas are just as
real as the neurons they inhabit as
James Blake tells us you know a new
kingdom rises above the biosphere the
denizens of this kingdom are ideas
because ideas have retained some of the
properties of organisms it turns out
they leap from brain to brain that can
beat for the limited resources of our
attention
they have infectivity they have
spreading power they are what Richard
Dawkins calls the new replicators born
from the primordial soup of human
culture they're vector of transmission
is language and electronic communication
and though ideas are not made of nucleic
acid they have achieved more
evolutionary change and at a rate leaves
the old gene panting far behind you know
Ray Kurzweil says our ability to create
virtual models in our heads combined
with our modest-looking thumbs was
sufficient to usher in a secondary force
of evolution of home technology and it
will continue until the entire universe
is at our fingertips this is
unbelievable stuff it speaks to the
telescoping nature of evolutionary
change
change in the last hundred years than in
the last billion years Terence Mckenna
actually wrote from the moment that
human beings invented language
biological evolution essentially ceased
and evolution became a cultural
epigenetic phenomenon now we take in
matter of low organization we put it
through our mental filters and we
extrude it in the form of space shuttles
and iPhones
you know the imaginary foundation tells
us that what imagination does is allows
us to conceive of delightful future
possibilities pick the most amazing one
and pull the present forward to meet it
you know imagine how impoverished this
world would have been if we hadn't
invented the technology of the oil
painting the time for Van Gogh for the
technology of the musical instrument of
time for Beethoven and Mozart to unfurl
through it you know with the revolutions
in biotechnology nanotechnology the free
exchange of information is allowing us
to conceive of radical new things
Freeman Dyson says in the future new
generation of artists will be writing
genomes which was blue and say the Blake
and Byron Road versus what is great and
man said Nietzsche is that he is a
bridge and not an end you know we're on
a trajectory so right in the middle
between the born and the made Road Kevin
Kelley and so radical openness it's huge
it's a universe of possibility it's gray
and fused by color it's the invisible
revealed it's the mundane blown away by
oh we need to cultivate radical openness
as a way of participating and
accelerating evolution
[Music]